I'll forego him Rose - welcome to the
last episode probably considering where
Dubrow said last episode of the main
story we heard we ended in a quiet a
cliffhanger easy to find someone who
could get small or could perform
abortions but both but both so yeah what
Randy just said we're gonna have to
become small look he's all small we're
gonna go inside this homosexual man's
anus and perform it are you ready for
this I don't think you can be ready for
something like this but let's that's
supposed to be is sorry okay the [ __ ] do
I go in I never thought I'd actually say
that Oh be careful
I might've also put some bass up there
the other night what have you changed to
butters or something I wonder why this
is this is so [ __ ] typical South Park
boy I love the episode where where
what's the name fatal Burt or something
has the rat has to come out of his anus
or something hey I love that I get every
I gotta listen to that after this all
right we have to disarm the snuke
somehow I don't [ __ ] know Oh
behind you is blocked by the large
finger please play the song don't we
have to yes is waiting for you journey
onward new kid or you will soon be dead
road is full of danger and fright but
push onward new kid with all of your
might okay dookey dookey
oh but aren't we supposed to disarm this
I'm so glad they incorporated this part
that's very nice
oh it's so every way that makes sense
right it's [ __ ] sick man it's that Oh
for [ __ ] sake what is that oh god nope
nope nope what the hell is that what is
that okay I got the first attack
whatever that is I regenerates their
eyes - wait I have a nuke oh it's the
Nagasaki yes of course
all right let's play good Egypt this
[ __ ] oh no it's immune well what are
we gonna do then what if we just attack
it that works hammer of but it should be
pretty good
yeah no we [ __ ] them that's what we
did - hey you syringe how the hell are
we that corn why would you stick corn up
you uh why am i climb babies next
[ __ ] what is this
how am I Oh buddy command who can do
that fighters really know about us can
do [ __ ] about us
you gotta go who would be good with
technology no I doubt it
are we really gonna go to sleep at your
word is the command my lord all right
what okay thank you
oh no what is that it that that it's a
Nazi hat okay that's great let's use
butters cuz he seems pretty awesome in
this situation hey now Anthony all right
can we shoot that maybe oh that was easy
oh there's I didn't see it okay of
course that would be an alien probe way
up here all right
you don't need to describe what is that
mr. hat you suck Oh a new friend thank
you
I can we do something else we have to
attack it Nagasaki yes and so do you
[ __ ] get you Nazi [ __ ] all right
let's keep going
I hope can I answer big gay
no I didn't see it with fine
now come on the [ __ ] is that magic oh
[ __ ]
alright buddies you better do something
good here all right you know I'll I'll
shut up yeah that went well that was
done better
well otherwise it'd be a boring game
Whitney vibra blade really really
[ __ ] really real well
why the [ __ ] not oh we already equipped
it that's that's great that's this great
what if we might as well modify any
wooden a shock damage and perfect attack
okay I am a nine year old with that with
a B that looks okay looks like an it
goddamn nukes you goddamn sneak
[ __ ] what is this [ __ ] I need a
lock never seen that before
why can't we find a lock inside an
[ __ ] this is not a game but us it's
not a game I wouldn't go down here oh
that's the bat hi we're gonna have to
find something else what about here what
let that'll make the flashlight work try
the button new kid hmm it's a bat then
it's a flashlight oh my god
thank you stop putting stuff in your
anus god damn it
condom Kenneth gain the Sheila for her
pleasure
ribbed for her pleasure huh great it's
not a little gnome - what is this what
are these you know what I don't want to
know I bet I don't like you I was once
used for pleasure as an anal plaything
and thus perished in this place now you
must defeat by angry spirits in order to
move forward I know I don't really sound
that angry but trust me okay no I don't
want to fight you don't such a catchy
sign
help I can download it later
all right he's almost answer oh let's
just finish him off
ya little [ __ ] one more hand
there's armor that I got is is perfect
man okay well we always win cuz they're
[ __ ] awesome buddy you have proven
yourself in combat young anal plaything
you made journey forth find the snuke
trigger and save the outside world
fare thee met and fatty well so what
else is the animals I know there was a
frog in the bird I know there's one
where I think how do you know that are
there's something up there
well what about Nagasaki yes Nagasaki
always does actually but is I did
you're finally right is that an oh [ __ ]
oh there was one there where am I
supposed to teleport then you know what
I'm not sure if I want to know what that
I didn't join the company for this we've
got our orders yeah but how come we
always get the [ __ ] jobs go clean out
the barracks go round up civilians in
their homes go from gay man's butt home
guard against intruders [ __ ] sucks
fix to blow up the city clearly doesn't
want anyone stopping them you must get
past that new kid don't [ __ ] him up oh
yes I will [ __ ] them up that's what I
wanted oh boy
alright think of David all this it's my
favorite oh that really didn't do much
okay we're gonna need something good
from your buddies come on shield yes
awesome
alone the shield lay at 14 it's like
easy mode on long they just keep our
holiday tell my wife I was the madding
James so romantic
alright the circumcised that little
[ __ ] here you go sir almost dead now
maybe buddies can finish him
yeah I didn't expect to see you solder
into this place but hey I never expect
to see one what the [ __ ] is this is that
the snuke hey yes hello new kid i am
catatafish the trigger of the
thermonuclear device lies before you I
have tried to solve its riddle but I
have been unable to disarm it
there are only moments to spare find a
way to disengage the trigger or all will
be lost
it seems as I just updated the game and
it seems to become even buggier now I
don't know what's fine before
there's such genius or coming up with
[ __ ] like this like no show the world is
stuff like okay
oh yeah anybody's know okay maybe Kyle I
don't know what he can do it handicapped
sign you need a part of course shoulda
known yep where'd is the Canadian I do
it alright just give me one second
this calls for a little bar de cactus
Bartok axes huh okay
smooth abortion sequence initiated what
be in confusion
I was worried we're not gonna be able to
do this twice there we go initiate
control
that's not the vagina nah wrong chick Oh
seriously scares me
what am i doing my doing a
I like my hat by the way hope you like
it too that's worried we're not gonna be
able to do this more than once but guess
that was fun
come on suck it out
hello
yeah please take your time what the [ __ ]
so [ __ ] weird yeah we got the damn
snow not anyone can do that [ __ ] I'm
gonna put that on my resume
great job new kid but your journey is
not yet complete we need your services
again we would come no thanks
am I gonna be team douchebag now great
job you pissed on this nuke is saved
once and for all it's never been so
ready to do anything in my life but
first stop pudding stop up Uranus crown
of anal pleasure that's right [ __ ]
that's right [ __ ] that goes on my
you're a better man than I knew kid if
you want to go take a shower and come
back we'll wait it was very brave what
you did in that man's butthole it's one
way to put it I guess all right let's
finish this Allah ended with that one
that's too good all right
that's going here you thought you could
conquer the fortress of darkness why
back away from that stuff but I have yet
to complete my RT you have come to
witness the power of darkness stop
you have no yeah ha greed sauce from
Taco Bell I took it from their
construction site not Taco Bell sauce
then why'd I fight it at Taco Bell it
leaked out of a UFO glad it's toxic goo
from another galaxy
think about it since when does Taco Bell
have a green sauce dude actually since
about a year ago all right Taco Bell has
green sauce now no way they've had it
longer than a year I've always gotten
spicy green burritos yeah no one's
saying in the packets they just started
putting green sauce in packets dafuq how
the [ __ ] did I missed it
ha I don't seem so foolish now do I that
doesn't mean you can throw on the screen
sauce yes [ __ ] ya Clyde why do you think
that shit's glowing maybe because of the
three varieties of Chili Peppers doesn't
give us this dick at home or what you'll
beat me up yeah come on just put your
foot on a
what is this oh my god do you really
chef nah come on chocolate salty ball
[ __ ] hey what are we gonna do all right
let's first circumcise him that's gross
I don't want to go near him bet you need
to drop his armor to Labe all right now
your job power cord what is that whoa
Oh give me PPE that helps now great
all right Brown Oh baby oh nice it's
very nice
all right and now and slinger david
knapp aired it out huh that sounds good
an amazing feat of skill there ones she
didn't talk much but boy did she
battle I had a nice manse that she said
come on set up on the maiden brimstone
Barry who is also your mom that's pretty
good
I know oh that's not too bad oh [ __ ]
what is he doing now
okay I'm definitely using mana now
we go oh god damn I thought it would
stun him
Oh No oh okay Shay [ __ ] [ __ ]
did it work okay good know what hello
children
Oh what the [ __ ] don't do it
none touch me children you are sick I
think some Nazi chick
so I don't know if you Brewin Brazil but
the story about the chef's character is
that the voice actor was a Scientologist
and they made the episode where they
made fun of Scientology which was a
really good episode by the way but he
had to quit being a voice actor because
of that and of course what they did was
they they murdered his character in the
worst way possible long is boss battle
ever men are in this game at least what
is this dude it's so nasty man hello
children
oh [ __ ] come on [ __ ] that did more
damage to him than me that's awesome
he's dead but I don't think he's quite
undead what the [ __ ] are you talking
about
spotting Dominic who almost got ahead
finishing baby what what hard that bit
for chef guy man darkness okay you know
I'm not playing anymore you have broken
the rules of this ticket for that I
vanished oh [ __ ]
calm down card bang we did it dude that
was awesome you did it your noble Quest
is at an end and for all your deeds and
all your time put into this I hereby
promote you to king douchebag
congratulations
alright Prez gonna have to end the
episode here I can't upload longer
because my internet situation right now
and 23 minutes is already kind of
pushing it but I hope you enjoyed
watching will be the absolute final
episode in an in the next one it is to
quite a bit of while left and we do have
side quests as well to play around with
so anyway I want to thank you both for
watching leave a like if you enjoyed I
really appreciate it and I'll see you
tomorrow with in the final one I promise
sorry